vamos a tomarnos un conjunto que
contenga un par de vectores en r2 para
preguntarnos cuál es el espacio
vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores así que me voy a tomar dos
vectores me voy a tomar el vector 23 y
también me voy a tomar el vector a 46 el
segundo vector base del vector 46 y
bueno si yo me quiero preguntar cuál es
el espacio vectorial que está generado
por estos dos vectores entonces lo que
se me ocurre pensar es en una
combinación lineal de estos dos vectores
por lo tanto voy a poner que una
y voy a ver a dónde puedo llegar
recuerdan que también lo podemos ver
como cuáles son todos los vectores que
podemos representar con estos dos
vectores con una combinación lineal de
estos dos vectores así que voy a tomar
una constante uno que va a multiplicar
al primer vector al vector dos tres más
una constante 2 que va a multiplicar el
segundo vector es decir al vector 46 y
bueno ya tengo una combinación lineal de
estos dos vectores sin embargo este
segundo vector lo puedo ver como un
múltiplo del primer vector de hecho este
segundo vector es exactamente lo mismo
que tomar métodos
es el primer vector entonces déjenme
escribir lo que multiplica el vector 23
más de 2 que multiplica y este vector lo
voy a ver a continuación como dos veces
el vector 232 por dos son cuatro dos por
tres son seis y estos dos son lo mismo
por lo tanto lo voy a escribir como dos
veces el vector dos tres y si substituyó
aquí abajo me va a quedarse 2 que
multiplica a dos veces el vector 23 y
bueno si te das cuenta este de aquí es
el doble que el primer vector esto es un
múltiplo del primer vector por lo tanto
yo puedo escribir esto de la siguiente
manera esto es uno más dos veces se 2
todo esto que multiplica el vector 23
pero lo interesante de todo esto es que
una constante más dos veces otra
constante pues es lo mismo que otra
constante al final esto es un numerito
que no cambia es una constante
entonces le puede llamar c3 que
multiplica el vector 23 y entonces en
este momento estoy obteniendo un
resultado muy importante el resultado es
que la combinación lineal de estos dos
vectores del vector 23 y el vector 46
y me da una sola constante que
multiplica a mi vector 23 y de igual
manera puede haber hecho esto con un
medio de este vector pero lo importante
es que obtuve uno de los dos vectores
como un múltiplo del otro vector y por
lo tanto obtengo este resultado y con
esto obtengo que al final una
combinación lineal de dos vectores me da
de resultado un escalar que multiplica a
un solo vector y por lo tanto como se ve
esto en r2 bueno nosotros sabemos que
nosotros tenemos un escalar que
multiplica a un vector nos da una línea
recta aquí tengo mi vector 23 y si lo
multiplicó por cualquier constante
entonces tarde o temprano voy a obtener
una recta así que vamos a dibujarla esta
va a ser por aquí por aquí también 23
caminos 23 para acá y obtengo esta línea
recta por lo tanto estoy diciendo que el
espacio vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores es esta línea recta fíjate muy
bien desde los primeros vídeos yo
análisis sé que cuando tenía una
constante que multiplicaba un vector
obtenía una línea recta no es así y si
esta combinación lineal
al final una constante que multiplica
una línea recta entonces puedo decir que
el espacio vectorial que me dan estos
dos vectores el vector 23 y el vector 46
este conjunto que yo tenía en un
principio me da de resultado esta recta
que yo obtengo aquí este es un espacio
vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores y es que al final date cuenta
que el vector 46 está sobre la misma
recta vamos a tomar otro color y vamos a
dibujar al vector 46 en su posición
estándar tengo que caminar 4 a la
derecha y después de caminar 6 hacia
arriba yo obtengo este vector anaranjado
que estoy dibujando aquí lo que me está
diciendo que el vector 23 del vector 46
son vectores pues lineales es decir
existen en una misma recta y esto
estamos hablando en el plano cartesiano
y ahora la pregunta es si están en una
línea recta cómo puedo yo obtener otro
vector
supongamos este nuevo vector que voy a
dibujar dado una combinación lineal de
estos dos vectores y la respuesta es que
no hay forma de obtener este otro vector
porque siempre estamos condenados a
obtener vectores sobre esta misma línea
no podemos separarnos de esta línea
recta si sólo tenemos este conjunto con
estos dos vectores nuestros destinos
quedarnos siempre en esta línea recta y
es justo por eso que cuando nosotros
hicimos una combinación lineal con estos
dos vectores al final obtuvimos una
constante que multiplicaba a uno de
ellos y es aquí cuando voy a introducir
una definición muy importante que vamos
a ver bastante en este vídeo a estos dos
vectores se les conoce como linealmente
dependientes y linealmente dependientes
significa que uno de los vectores de
este conjunto se puede representar con
una combinación lineal de los otros
vectores de este conjunto o tal vez otra
forma de verlo es que estos vectores no
nos dan una información nueva o nos da
una nueva dirección al final podemos
representar a uno de estos vectores como
una combinación lineal de los otros
vectores y en este caso fue que el
vector 46 lo podíamos ver como dos veces
el vector 23 o inclusive lo podemos ver
mucho mejor en r3 si tenemos un vector y
otro vector los cuales no son vectores
co lineales entonces los que nos van a
generar
un plano un plano en r3 tengo este plano
en r3 y si ahora yo me tomo un tercer
vector porque estamos en el espacio y
este vector está encima de este mismo
plano entonces lo que va a pasar es lo
siguiente no obtenemos una nueva
dirección estamos sobre la misma
dirección de este mismo plano por lo
tanto seguimos trabajando en dos
dimensiones en lugar de movernos a una
tercera dimensión esto es lo que pasa
porque este tercer vector es un vector
linealmente dependiente a los otros dos
y es que al final este plano que estoy
dibujando es el plano que abarcan estos
dos vectores o es el espacio vectorial
que están generando estos dos vectores
esto quiere decir que cualquier vector
en este plano lo podemos ver como una
combinación lineal de estos dos vectores
y por lo tanto si este vector de verde
está sobre este plano por lo tanto lo
podemos ver como una combinación lineal
de estos otros dos vectores que me
generaban este plano de amarillo y por
lo tanto este vector de verde que estoy
dibujando aquí no está aportando nada al
espacio vectorial formado por estos dos
vectores es decir no está
dando una nueva dimensión y un nuevo
espacio ninguna manera distinta de
movernos y por lo tanto esto hace que
este vector de verde sea linealmente
dependiente de estos otros dos vectores
que eran a su vez linealmente
independientes porque generaban este
plano y es que para que estos tres
vectores puedan formar algo que no sea
un plano algo parecido a r3 empiezan a
generar cosas distintas lo que tiene que
pasar es que este vector va a tener que
romper este plano romper estas dos
dimensiones y moverse en una nueva
dirección y si este vector está
rompiendo este plano entonces quiere
decir que está afuera de este plano y si
está fuera de este plano entonces está
fuera de cualquier combinación lineal de
estos dos vectores porque me está
generando cosas nuevas estoy diciendo
que estos tres vectores son linealmente
independientes así que déjenme dibujarse
un par de ejemplos más vamos a tomarnos
el vector 23 y vamos a tomarnos también
al director a 72
y también no voy a tomar el tercer
vector el cual va a ser el 95
tengo un conjunto de tres vectores y
bueno lo que quiero saber es si este
conjunto de estos tres vectores es
linealmente dependiente o es realmente
independiente y bueno lo primero que
podemos ver es que ninguno de estos es
múltiplo del otro si yo multiplico dos
veces por el vector uno por el vector
dos nunca me del vector 3 ni nada así
sin embargo si hacemos un poco más de
análisis nos vamos a dar cuenta que el
vector uno más del vector 2 es el vector
3 y por lo tanto estoy diciendo que el
vector 3 lo podemos representar como una
combinación lineal del vector 1 y del
vector 2 por lo tanto podría decir que
este conjunto es un conjunto linealmente
dependiente porque encontré que el
tercer vector lo puedo escribir como una
combinación lineal de estos dos vectores
a ver vamos a verlo con más calma en el
plano cartesiano estoy aquí trabajando
en r2 y me voy a dibujar el primer
vector mi primer vector es el vector 2 3
y después voy a dibujar también mi
segundo vector para ver si así podemos
entender mejor
lo que se refiere es linealmente
dependiente y linealmente independiente
como definición el vector 23 es este de
aquí este es mi vector 1 y después tengo
el vector 7 2 hay que caminar 7 a la
derecha y estoy más o menos por acá y 2
hacia arriba estoy en este punto de aquí
por lo tanto este es el vector que estoy
representando con el 72 este es mi
vector 2 y ahora quiero que te des
cuenta que estos dos vectores como si
son linealmente independientes entonces
su espacio generado por estos dos su
espacio vectorial generado por ver uno y
por b 2 es todo r 2 es todo el plano
cartesiano es decir que cualquier punto
en el plano cartesiano lo podemos ver
como una combinación lineal de estos dos
vectores cualquier sector que yo me tomé
y que esté viviendo en r2 lo puedo ver
como una combinación lineal de estos dos
vectores así que déjame dibujarse el
tercer vector el tercer factor va a ser
este de azul que es el vector 95 y este
vector 95 está viviendo en r 2 y si
estás viviendo en él
por lo tanto estoy diciendo que lo
podemos ver como una combinación lineal
tanto de b1 b2 por el simple hecho de
vivir en r2 y si nosotros tenemos que el
espacio vectorial generado por ver uno y
por b2s r2 entonces como éste vive en r2
no hay de otra se puede ver como una
combinación lineal de b1 y b2 y por lo
tanto estamos diciendo que el vector 3
es linealmente dependiente del vector 1
y el vector 2 así que vamos a ver otro
ejemplo para que siga sentando mejor el
conocimiento no voy a tomar en esta
ocasión al vector 70 al cual voy a
llamar mi vector 1 no voy a tomar el
siguiente vector el vector 0 -1 este va
a ser mi vector 2 y bueno tal vez vaya a
ser un poco obvio lo que voy a decir
pero bueno lo que quiero ver si este
conjunto de vectores el 70 y el 0 -1 es
un conjunto de linealmente dependiente o
linealmente independiente y como lo
puedo saber
bueno pues voy a tomar una constante 1
que va a multiplicar el vector 1 y voy a
ver si puedo generar el vector
lo único que estoy utilizando es la
definición de linealmente dependiente o
linealmente independiente si son
linealmente independientes entonces no
va a existir una combinación lineal que
me dé el otro vector así que pongo se
uno por el primer vector que es el
vector 70 y date cuenta que la segunda
componente es 0 así que cualquier cosa
que multiplique por 0 nunca nunca me va
a dar menos 1 esto quiere decir que el
segundo vector nunca lo voy a poder ver
como el primer vector multiplicado por
un escalar y de igual manera para el
segundo vector cuando yo lo multiplique
por una constante en la primera
componente nunca me va a quedar nada
distinto de cero por lo tanto nunca voy
a obtener el 7 y por lo tanto se puede
decir que el segundo vector multiplicado
por un escalar nunca se va a aparecer al
primer vector y bueno vamos a dibujarlos
para ver cómo se ven dos vectores
linealmente independientes tengo este
vector y este vector y si te das cuenta
estos dos sectores generan todo el plano
garcía no el espacio vectorial que
generan estos dos vectores estolano
cartesiano así que déjame ponerlo el
espacio vectorial que genera de uno
es igual a todo r2 a todo el plano
cartesiano pues son vectores linealmente
independientes y aquí no puse que
generaban estos tres vectores así que
dejamos escribirlo el espacio vectorial
generado tanto por ver uno como por de
dos como por b tres por los tres
vectores quién va a ser bueno si b1 y b2
generaban todo el plano cartesiano
entonces estos tres vectores también van
a generar el plan cartesiano porque al
final aunque tenemos uno que es
combinación lineal de los otros dos es
decir era la suma del primer vector más
el segundo el vector
aquí están aunque tengamos estos tres
dos me generaban todo el plano
cartesiano pues además me generan al
vector 3 y por lo tanto me siguen
generando estos tres vectores todo el
plano casiano o dicho tal manera todo r2
y es que al final aquí estoy dando tres
vectores y estoy dando un poco más de
información para que me generen
r2 sin embargo este vector 3 sería como
completamente redundante ponerlo porque
al final con b 1 y con b 2 solamente con
estos dos vectores generábamos r2 el
espacio vectorial generado por ver 1 por
b 2 es la versión simplificada del
espacio vectorial generado x
1 2 y 3 es como la forma óptima de verlo
es como cuando tenemos un problema con
más datos que los datos que necesitamos
por lo tanto bueno esta información es
redundante y puede haber un tercer
ejemplo este tercer ejemplo lo voy a
tomar en r3 para que veamos y acabemos
este vídeo vamos a tomar los vectores
con tres componentes porque estamos
pensando en vectores 93 y 90 más los
siguientes vectores me voy a tomar el
vector 200 este va a ser el primer
vector 200 lo voy a tomar como segundo
vector él
el 010 vamos a tomarnos el 010 y como
tercer vector el 0 0 7 el 0 0 7 como si
fuera agente secreto y bueno ya que
tengo estos tres vectores ahora la
pregunta es la siguiente el conjunto de
estos tres vectores es un conjunto de
vectores linealmente independientes o
linealmente dependientes y bueno pues la
respuesta es muy sencilla porque si yo
veo estos vectores y me fijo en el
tercer vector entonces lo voy a dar
cuenta que el vector 1 y el vector 2 con
cualquier combinación lineal que tenga
nunca me va a dar en su tercer
componente 7 porque al final date cuenta
que cuando yo multiplico una constante
por 0 después otra constante por 0 nunca
me van a dar 7 de igual manera si te
muestro los dos nunca me van a dar en su
segunda componente 1 y si todos los 2
nunca me van a dar en su primer
componente 2 lo que quiere decir que
este es un conjunto de vectores
linealmente independientes
y son linealmente independientes en r3
recuerda que esto quiere decir que
entonces ninguno de estos vectores lo
puedo ver como combinación lineal de los
otros dos y entonces como se verían sus
de vectores gráficamente si yo estuviera
en esta ocasión no en el plano sino en
r3 este podría ser el primer vector el
vector 200 en el eje de las x este de
aquí voy a suponer que un segundo vector
en el eje de la jez y este va a ser mi
tercer vector en el eje de las setas
director 007 y si te das cuenta acabo de
generar a todo r3 o dicho de otra manera
estoy moviéndome en tres dimensiones con
estos vectores lo que quiere decir que
el espacio vectorial generado por estos
tres vectores me va a dar todo r3 el
espacio vectorial generado por el
conjunto de sus de vectores es todo
r3 y bueno espero que hasta aquí me
hayas entendido bien porque en el
siguiente vídeo lo que quiero ver es una
definición más formal de lo que es
linealmente independiente y linealmente
dependiente y además quiero trabajar
contigo muchos más ejemplos de todo esto